I'm not joking. There's going to be some insane degen fantasy
[__] on that account. First indication that it's
still critically people support. Are you saying that's what's
implied by this face you're making? I did not wake up this morning
and think, you know what? My life is pretty good and peaceful.
I should burn it down. There is a backstory here.
it has come out
that Grant Planter may have cheated on his wife. He certainly
sent
before they were married, all right? And his wife flagged these
things to his campaign, to an aid in the campaign, and that aid
later sold those or released them publicly, I'm not sure which.
And it's become a scandal in and of itself. So, this was released
yesterday, this came out yesterday.
Grant Planter, now I'm not going to say, oh well, you're just
mad he has things. No, it's not quite that. Obviously,
obviously Grant Planter, you know, cheating on his wife, that's
that's bad. I don't know precisely like what their dynamic is.
I don't know exactly what's going on there. So, I'd have to read
a little bit more. What I've noticed around this is it's gone
way beyond what you would think here. Like, it the response to
it has basically overplayed its hand again, in my opinion. Does
this mean he has to run for president? Well, we'll see.
They're certainly doing everything they can to make him seem
cool.
Like a bad boy, but, you know, we're going to read the article
really
It's the Wall Street Journal article. Grant Planter's wife flagged
sexually explicit texts to his Senate campaign. The wife of the
main Democratic Senate candidate last year told the campaign
about texts she had found between Planter and other women. There
is one very concerning part here, I will say, okay? And that's
that apparently he was sexting people on Kik, k i k.
Now, if you know anything about that app, that app is basically
only used by the most degenerate folk on the planet. I'm not
joking. That app, like you you hear that app's name and it's
like, "Oh, every person with every fetish on the planet are the
people who use this, right?" Kik still exists? Apparently, yeah.
Kik is a high-key Well, that's the funny thing is a lot of people
aren't focusing in on that. I focused in on that. I tweeted about
it the other day. Dude, it yesterday, it's the the KIK Kik app
is like honestly a huge red flag in and of itself.
is it Kik is worse? I'm not joking. I think it might be. I think
it might actually be worse. Like having Like dude, it's actually
worse than having a tattoo. Okay, days after Grand Planter announced
his main Senate bid, his wife informed the campaign about a potential
political problem she had previously discovered on the oyster
farmer's phone.
Explicit texts with several women, according to people familiar
with the matter. Amy Gertler, who married Planter in 2023, told
the campaign about messages she had found early in their marriage
in the spring of 2025.
In late August, on some aids or some aids were conducting opposition
research on their own candidate. Gertler disclosed the texts
to a campaign aid and to make sure they didn't pose a risk to
her husband's nascent campaign.
Aids ultimately decided the texts were a private matter and that
being handled uh that was being handled by the couple in marriage
counseling, a campaign official said. In a statement provided
by Planter's campaign, Gertler said she believed she was confiding
in an aid she considered a friend. The previously unreported
deliberations last year over explicit texts discovered on Planter's
phone come as a the veteran has exploded onto the national political
scene kindling Democratic hopes that they can unseat Republican
Senator Susan Collins and gain control of the Senate.
On Kik and not a teenager post-2016 that you are So, it's possible.
Well, it's it Listen,
I don't know. I don't know about that. But I do know, like I
said, this guy is definitely into some weird
Which like is okay, so long as it doesn't involve Kik. The kids.
That's it. You can do You can do some
Do some weird Just don't involve kids in it, okay?
The Wall Street Journal verified the account on the app, a messaging
platform that has been widely used for encounters. The account
is listed with the user ID P Hustle 0331
or similar to other social media handles that Platner has used
including Reddit and a now deleted Instagram account. It was
created in 2016.
Platner's campaign said the candidate had long deleted the app
from his phone but hadn't deactivated his account. Besides his
post on Reddit downplaying assault which became the subject of
an attack ad by his then primary opponent Janet Mills, Platner
also expressed lenient views related to infidelity in other posts.
Mills and Maine Governor Mills, sorry, the Maine the Maine Governor
suspended her campaign ahead of the June 9th Democratic primary.
In a Reddit post in December 2019, Platner said a politician
would frequently drink at the Tune Inn, a Washington D.C. watering
hole with lawmakers where Platner worked as a
The politician, Platner posted, would get wasted and brag about
all the chicks he was slaying who weren't his wife. "I've got
a pretty flexible moral compass when it comes to those things,"
Platner added in his post. The campaign declined to comment about
that post.
that's bad, right? Obviously, that's like that's bad that you're
cheating on your wife. I I do think that's bad. I I say that's
bad. But man, oh man, do people ever do people ever go crazy
about it, okay?
Oh, Jon Favreau had a tweet about this. It's getting a lot of
play. Hold on. I just say that if the reason you don't want to
support a candidate is because he and his wife chose not to share
that they went through marriage counseling to deal with infidelity,
that's your choice. But I do think there are other factors in
the race that will have more of a direct impact on your life.
It's like, dude, it's
I'm sorry. You could say this and maybe hey, if you've been cheated
on, your life got rocked by that and you want to say you can't
vote for that candidate because he cheated on his wife.
Okay, that's fine. But there are bigger fish to fry. There are.
And I just think what I'm going to see, what I would predict
from this, is we're going to see people go like, oh, well, so
you cannot vote for somebody over Gaza, but you'll vote for somebody
who's a cheater?
I feel like there will be people saying
And I just can't imagine taking them seriously, okay? The issues
there's probably more coming from a kick and so over. Like, here's
the thing. The best case scenario for having Kick is like he
was doing roleplay about like
rocky women while he was deployed or something. Like that's honest
to God, that's like the best case scenario for what he was doing
on Kick. I'm not joking. There's going to be some insane degen
fantasy [__] on that account. I promise you if they
if those messages were ever released.
Do I care?
No, as long as it doesn't involve kids, I seriously don't care,
okay? Platner could have my mom and I'd still vote for him, says
Kyle Kulinski. All right, Kyle. Now, that's a bold claim to live
I'm just I'm going to be real. I'm going to be like, I don't
care what happened so long as it's two consenting adults. That's
my position. I'm not going to pretend that Platner that like
Platner
could do more. I don't know what's been done on that that Kick
app that Kick app
I'll be honest, I've asked by I've been asked by people to sign
up for this app
And the context in which I'm being asked to sign up is like disturbing
every
Okay? I I know exactly what people use that app for or at least
the times I've been asked to like install it or something. I'm
like, no.
No. No, thank you. Like just
just that alone has led me to go, yeah, no, thanks.
Yeah, I don't think so. Yeah, I don't think so.
Hassan, if Cenk Uygur was pro-Israel and against Medicare for
all, the same blue no matter who Dems, working alongside the
Republicans to deny their own party majority in the Senate, would
be presenting him as the second coming of Jesus Christ.
This is just true. And it's actually crazy to watch. Like this
is going to break a This is going to be a major schism right
now.
And it's a major schism and I I promise you it is caused primarily
by how outspoken Graham is against Israel over everything else.
That outspoken position against If Graham was an outspoken
defender of Israel, they would go, "Obviously, he's not a Nazi.
Obviously, that tattoo is just Obviously, we need to vote for
him."
Democrats are now attacking Graham for Maine with no shame. Same
Democrats who told us to vote blue no matter who when it was
back when it was to back establishment candidates, are now stabbing
Platner in the back. Why? Guys like Cory Booker 100% work for
Israel. That's who's organizing this. I hate to agree with Cenk,
but it's It's like It's I don't even see it as Israel. I just
see it as like pro-Zionist people. They won't vote for this guy,
to be honest with you.
We've got
His wife made a statement. I think that could possibly be in
the article, but I'll watch it anyway,
>> So, this was yesterday, yesterday afternoon. This is
his wife, Amy. I wanted to make a statement today and Sorry,
I'm getting eaten by bugs.
Um I wanted to make a statement today in response to a couple
of news articles that are out there about my marriage to Graham.
Um >> Oh god, I just scrolled down and saw Laura Loomer.
In this video, I learned that Graham Platner and his wife have
been married since 2023. And not only do they have a marriage
counselor, but they each have their own therapists as well. I
Are we denigrating people going to therapy now? I do believe
this used to be a thing in politics, right? You used to never
even be able to say if you're like a politician running for president,
you couldn't even say that you're seeing a therapist. That would
be like disqualifying to run for president.
>> Um if you know me and Graham >> personally, you
know that we got married in 2023. Um we live in Sullivan. We've
got two dogs and we love each other >> Ooh. That's the
That's the silver bullet defense, right? Yeah, this guy's a vet.
This guy's a vet. Do you not want veterans who might have PTSD
from combat roles to seek therapy? To seek mental like tranquility,
being healthy and >> So, it makes me really angry, um,
disappointed,
and
I find it really shameful
>> Oh, I will say the egregious egregious thing is like
she did this for opposition research to help her husband, right?
That this could just be private and she did it to help her husband
and these these texts that she shared literally to say like I
just want to make sure these aren't going to be brought out by
somebody who he doesn't know, like one of the other parties to
attack his campaign and they went, "No, it's fine. Just keep
them private." And then the person she shared it with decided
to publicize them himself. >> Well, that there's a group
of media
and people who are willing to spread
gossip, um, instead of talking about real issues that Graham
is is running on, like healthcare and education and childcare.
I'm walking up and down my road right now. [laughter] And this
is [clears throat]
>> Is Genevieve MacDonald the person who has been like
the person who's been making a bunch of statements against the
campaign? Or is that a different person? >> 20th take.
It's very hard to do. But,
I just really wanted to make sure that everyone knows that Graham
and I have a great marriage. Marriage is hard. Being newly married
is hard. Being newly married and going through infertility is
hard. Being newly married, going through infertility, and a Senate
campaign is is hard. Um, I don't even know if I have the right
words to describe what we've [laughter] been going through, but,
um, our marriage counselor helps. Uh, my personal counselor helps.
Graham's personal counselor helps. Um, and we work on our mental
health every day. No marriage is perfect and
I I don't want a perfect marriage. I want my
>> It's just sad that like total Yeah, like total rats.
It It is They're rats, Ocasio-Cortez. Like the person, Genevieve
McDonald, rat. Should be run out of politics entirely, right?
Like Like totally run out of politics.
This is They joined She joined like a nascent campaign, obviously
with the intention to do this, right?
I'm sorry. It's It's so clear that you have only joined with
the intention of trying to put all this stuff out, of trying
to sewer this campaign, and they failed to do it in the primary,
and they're so intent on sinking any progressive movement in
America that they're willing to give up a Senate majority for
it. They're so against
They're so against this progressive movement that they will tank
a Senate majority intentionally, which is mind-blowing.
Given what the threat that Trump represents, it is mind-blowing.
So, she had to come out and give that whole broad statement like
that, which is just
Right? We've got another statement from them, and then we're
going to go to the CNN the CNN segment, and then we'll start
looking at other reactions, okay? >> Bernie, we heard Amy's
video saw Amy's video last night about this situation, the story
in the Times and the Journal. What would your statement be at
this
It's no surprise to me that the establishment media outlets are
just going to run gossip instead of wanting to talk about the
things that actually matter in this race, which are the real
the material realities that make the manners are working with.
These people are going to try to make this race about anything
but what it's supposed to be about, which is policy.
They never want to talk about policy.
Amy and I have a very loving and very happy marriage. Uh they
would very much like to try to rip that apart. We're going to
come after us in every awful way that they possibly can. And
we're just going to keep talking about the fact that the hospitals
are closing, the fact that child care facilities are closing,
the fact that teachers and nurses aren't paid enough, and the
fact that everybody down here continues to work harder and longer
and get less.
But, of course, the powers that be do not want us to talk about
that. And so, they're going to just do gossip instead.
>> His Kick profile pic was wild, too. I saw his Kick profile
pic. It is This is good response. It is very funny that with
the Kick profile pic it says that his tattoos are visible.
I know what they're trying to imply, that he like had the Nazi
tattoo out. He didn't. It's covered up, right? It's not visible
in his profile.
>> No. No, this is This is the amazing part. The Wall Street
Journal and New York Times ran stories without any evidence besides
the gossip from a former staffer. I'm sorry, that's uh that's
frankly journalistic malpractice.
>> Oh, I don't like that he just did that. That was very
stupid.
That's not stupid because it's not the human reaction. That's
not stupid because it's not But he just basically challenged
them. This is the the universal claim thing. No, that's not true.
They ran stuff They ran stuff without any evidence. You've almost
invited them to present evidence and discredit you.
that's the other thing about publishing this stuff. A bunch of
people are going to go look through their DMs to see if they
recognize or if they just recognize the name P Hustle.
It's very possible that we're going to see some new stuff come
out, right?
But anyway, it's I don't know. I feel like that That statement
didn't need to be made. It's actually not relevant. Whether it's
true or not, it's not relevant.
Right? So, we keep watching. >> We pushed back on it. They
wanted They did it anyways. So. >> you have a question?
So, are you confirming that the messages did not
>> What's that? >> Uh the messages, they did not
>> I'm confirming that what Genevieve McDonald said in
the New York Times is not true.
>> So, you never met with her about uncomfortable,
for lack of a better words, messages as the campaign was >> We
talked about things in Amy and I's marriage that we've gone through
over the years. We talked about that because that's our marriage,
and we discussed it with the campaign. What Genevieve McDonald
claims isn't true. So, >> Tricky language. Tricky language.
>> Just if you want to see the Kik profile picture, this
is it right here. This is the the Kik profile picture as it was,
okay? YEAH, THIS GUY WAS up to some crazy [__] on
Kik. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. There's some crazy [__] going on in that
app. He was definitely using it for some reason, 100%.
So, let's let's take a look at this. Lefty Maine candidate, Senate
candidate, Grant Plathner caught in scandal. The Democrat was
reportedly multiple women on the hookup app, Kik. Even his own
wife, Amy Gartner, flagged the explicit messages to his campaign
staff because she was worried it would explode. This is the same
guy with the Nazi-style tone cough tattoo.
Add it. Old Reddit post bragging about how a about a flexible
moral compass on cheating. Another day, another hypocritical
leftist exposed.
Where's the hypocrisy? This guy who cheated on his wife, maybe,
says he's got a flexible moral compass on cheating. AND IF THAT'S
NOT HYPOCRISY, I don't know what is.
That I disagree with that. I think that seems kind of [__]
but that seems very consistent, actually. That seems like totally
consistent to me.
Uh Dem- Don't Democrats have any candidates with morals in Maine
that they could run in place of Plathner?
Neither Susan Collins nor Janet Mills would ever have a scandal.
Why? Because they have integrity.
They have true, real integrity, guys. They would never ever ever
have a scandal like
>> Uh it's kind of mad.
I'm I'm so positive that nothing like this, these little character
issues, they can't affect this guy. This guy's tapped into a
message that's too powerful for that. Very, very similar to the
way that Trump did, right? He's He's tapped into a really powerful
message.
And it's just not this stuff won't derail him. Maybe there is
stuff that would derail him, but this isn't it,
We've got the next The next one here. This image was going around
from a lot of people.
I I kept control-effing in this stupid Wall Street Journal article.
I checked like eight different articles looking all over the
place for this quote
It turns out this is fake.
Somebody faked this screenshot, and it was getting passed around
like it was totally real.
Uh so, it's socialism or barbarism.
Thank you very much. I appreciate it. Five gifted subs over on
Twitch. Thank you, thank you, thank you. Thank you so much.
Okay, yes. Dude, I I couldn't believe this is going around like
it's real. It finally gets noted, right, that it's not real,
but so many people have spread this like it is real. Well, let's
take a look at this. This is Genevieve McDonald's statement
put out through Shannon Watts for some reason. I have no idea
why.
From Bangor Daily News, Planners campaign manager, Morris Katz,
tried to stop Genevieve McDonald from sharing information about
Planners infidelities, which he had since the beginning of the
campaign with threats of defaming her. Just want to be clear
where we are right now, Katz wrote in the message that McDonald
shared exclusively with Bangor Daily News. Bangor Daily News?
Oh, I guess it's a Maine local news network. I was like, dude,
I've never heard of this place before. I was like, dude, what
the
This Shannon Watts person is particularly despicable as well.
I see them spouting all kinds of misinformation on the timeline
all all over the place. Okay. Truly a a weirdo. The story goes
in its current iteration will communicate directly on the record
and by name that Genevieve violated the personal trust of Amy
and Graham and shared explicit falsehoods to sabotage the campaign.
How was that defamation?
Where is the defamation? They're saying this is explicitly not
a true story and that you ran with the story to sabotage their
campaign. I hope you've got some sort of statement on the record.
I hope you've got something on the record.
So, this is her statement. There are some details missing from
the story. I hope it will be updated. The Wall Street Journal
called me Friday morning. Wait, they didn't get all of the details
from you, but they ran with the story?
Who Who gave them the story?
The The Wall Street Journal called me Friday morning to tell
me they were running a story they had verified through multiple
sources. I spoke into them months ago off the record. So, it
was a courtesy call. I'd probably still get some blowback. After
the Wall Street Journal reached out to Platner, the Platner campaign
for comment, Morris Katz demanded that I call the Wall Street
Journal, retract my comments, and tell them their reporting was
inaccurate, and send him a recording of the call. When I refused
to lie for Platner's campaign, they sent me this text. Just want
to be clear on where we are right now. If the story goes in its
current iteration, we'll communicate directly on the record and
by name that Genevieve violated the personal trust of Amy and
Graham and shared explicit falsehoods to sabotage the campaign.
So, I went on record with the New York
Okay. I did not wake up this morning and think, "You know what?
My life is pretty good and peaceful. I should burn it down."
There is a backstory here. I will never allow myself to be threatened
and intimidated by some punk kid consultant from NYC.
Okay, but where did they get the information from? Hold on. Let's
just look at the Wall Street Journal. Wall Street Journal, who's
saying What's the sourcing here? Platner's wife flags explicit
text to his campaign the The wife of Maine Democratic Senate
candidate last year told the campaign about text she had found
between Platner and other women.
According to people familiar with the
Who are the people familiar with the matter? Like you you should
have more than one source, right? Yeah, it sounds like they're
pretty confident Genevieve's the only person they told. So, the
people who know better are Genevieve and people Genevieve told.
Okay, we've got two more tweets. They're Hutch tweets. Let's
check them out. So,
engulfed in Democratic Senate or sorry, Maine Democratic Senate
frontrunner Grant Planter engulfed in sex text
scandal after wife alerts campaign to explicit messages with
up to six women. And Hutch does a little emote of
Wow, the president is a I don't really care. I I don't really
think anyone cares. A cheated on his wife. I'm good with blue
no matter who in the most ex- in the extreme, but I waffle a
bit on gaslighting people about his flaws and vulnerabilities
as a candidate that should be fairly obvious. Yeah, it's not
ideal, but I'm obviously going to support the Democrat. Why is
this hard? Why instead go with actually none of this is a problem.
I Hold on. Yeah, it's not I If If all you said here was yeah,
it's not ideal, but I support him anyway, where's your indication
of support here?
Where's the indication that it's still critical people support?
Are you saying that's what's implied by this Face you're making?
Okay, anyway, learn to read. I know you won't, so here's the
TLDR. His wife over a year ago showed his aids the texts. They
went to counseling privately, worked it out, and are happier
for it. The aid for clout or money showed the texts to the media.
Stop the feigned pearl clutching.
This was 1 year ago. I'm glad they got counseling and seem to
be working through what happened, but that's a pretty big sign
of recklessness and impulsivity from Planter. It is reasonable
to worry about his judgment and vulnerability to blackmail should
he win and up again. Wait, we think there's worse blackmail?
Well,
there there could be said as he defends Destiny. He would say
Destiny's not a candidate for office.
I mean, realistically,
I You see this he defends Destiny on, so we know that he doesn't
really have a functioning moral compass or a Yeah, I I I would
say a functioning moral compass because because of the way he
defended Destiny on the recent thing that came up. Reckless and
impulsive like a married Gavin Newsom having an affair with his
campaign manager's wife?
You're going to worry about his judgment or vulnerability? Should
he Should he bring it up again? Or is this just more performative
pearl clutching from you?
This is particularly dumb This is a particularly dumb attempt
at a gotcha. One, yes, that was also impulsive and bad. Two,
it was like 20 years ago and has been acknowledged and owned.
And so it doesn't represent the same kind of vulnerability as
what Platner did a year ago and never addressed publicly.
Wait, did Gavin Newsom bring this up before he was threatened
with it in some
Did Gavin Newsom just pop out of the woodwork and go, "I cheated
on my wife. I just thought you guys should know." Did that happen?
Or did Was somebody pushing him on it and he announced it? I
actually don't know which one it would be. You have a guy railing
against the Biden admin using Manchin's daughter daughter's obvious
crimes as leverage. You had no issue with Manchin being vulnerable
to
Well, okay.
Yeah, Hutch is just I I called this immediately that he will
just focus in on all of Platner's downsides as much as he possibly
can because he thinks it will lead to the failure of Platner
as a candidate and that will prove his worldview, right?
And he will do that while still saying, "Well, I'm technically
blue no matter who I'm technically endorsing." And it's like,
"Dude, who cares about your endorsement? What is the broad base
of your coverage like? What is the broad base of your coverage
like? The same argument you made about Kolklinski and all of
these other people. What is your coverage like?